JOHN GABRIELI: A very large
number of children just
aren't having the reading skills
they need to succeed in school.
The statistics in the US
are that so many children
are behind because of
learning differences,
because of poverty.
The more we understand about
how the mind and brain learns,
the more we might be able
to use that knowledge
to enhance outcomes
for many learners
at all stages of the lifespan
One area that I think would
be fantastic to really grow
is the use of
technology in education.
Technology has revolutionized
practically every aspect
of our lives.
It has not moved education
forward one iota.
There is almost no evidence that
anything we do in technology
has helped kids read better,
do math better, have better
social, emotional well-being.
In fact, we're going the
opposite way on that.
Rates of depression and
anxiety are up in adolescence.
Even before COVID,
in the United States,
we've had a clear
mental health crisis,
especially amongst adolescents
and young adults, which
is so worrying and touching
so many families' lives.
Some of the research
directions we're pursuing
is early identification
of risks,
so you don't wait until a child
is in a full-blown depression,
and then you can
hopefully do something
on behalf of their child.
We know technology can
be amazingly powerful.
It can be highly
personalized to individuals.
And so we think that that's
a huge both opportunity
and challenge to say, what
can we do using the best
that we understand about
modern technology, which
has revolutionized practically
every sphere of our life,
except educational outcomes
on behalf of children?
We want the kinds of skills
in technology and science
and engineering that
are so amazing at MIT
to be aimed at issues of
educational improvement.
That kind of system between
scientific knowledge
and implementation has
not occurred very well
in education.
We just haven't had
much of a system
to say, oh, if we know
something about how learning can
be improved, whether
it's learning to read,
STEM learning, social,
emotional well-being on behalf
of children, how do we
know what program works,
for whom it works, and how
to implement it effectively?
I think that MIT can contribute
to this sphere of opportunity
in social equity--
is to push not only the
technology and the science,
but also a scientific approach
to saying what really works,
and for whom.
[MUSIC PLAYING]